burgers are a staple across american
barbecues all summer long that said a
lot of people don't know how to make the
best burger ever that's where we come in
we're going to show you how
a great burger requires great high
quality meat you want to make sure that
you have the right proportion of fat
content we'd recommend going between 70
30 to 80 20. any blend in that range has
just enough fat to keep the burger
together juicy and flavorful you also
want to know how much meat to get if
you're making a diner style burger it's
about four ounces of meat per person if
you're making a pub style burger it's
about eight ounces of meat per person
last but not least you want to know what
cuts to put in your ground beef blend
the most common cuts are chuck short rib
and round we'd recommend talking to your
butcher and seeing what they have on
hand and what they'd recommend if you
don't have a butcher on hand most
grocery stores will offer a pre-made
burger blend or you can go for one of
the ratios we mentioned it's really
important that you're only buying meat
that is usda inspected now that you know
what meat to buy we're going to go over
two recipes for how to make a diner
style burger and a pup style burger
first up is the diner style burger also
called a smash burger this is always
done on a griddle cast iron or skillet
first you're going to divide your meat
into four ounce portions if you don't
have a scale this is about the size of a
tennis ball heat a skillet or cast iron
pan over high heat when it's just about
to smoke add a bit of oil now you're
going to take the four ounce ball of
meat and generously season it with salt
and pepper emphasis on the generous
place the season side of the meat
directly into the pan with two spatulas
you're going to smash your burger down
into a patty you want to make sure that
the patty is pretty flat so that it can
get a nice even crust you cook it for
about a minute and a half to two minutes
and then flip and cook it for another
minute and a half to two minutes if
you're into a cheeseburger as soon as
you flip that's when you add the cheese
we'd recommend going the classic fruit
with something like american or cheddar
cheese use a thermometer to make sure
that the meat is cooked to 160 to 165
degrees
now that your patties are done the next
easy upgrade is to toast your buns
brush your buns with melted butter and
then place them on the hot pan this will
go really fast it'll take between 20 and
40 seconds until your bun is toasted
we'd recommend going with any type of
soft bun to contrast the crispy exterior
of a smash burger the order of how
burgers are stacked is often debated
some people put the lettuce on top
that's totally fine we put ours on the
bottom to prevent the bun from getting
soggy for the most part it doesn't make
much of a difference next up pub style
burgers pub style burgers are
significantly larger than a diner style
burger these are big guys with pup style
burgers you're going to season your meat
before you form a patty you should
always use salt and pepper or you can
get creative with other seasonings
you're going to take your seasoned meat
and form it into a classic patty form
once the grill is preheated add the
patty and cook it without moving for
three to four minutes flip the burger
over and cook it for an additional three
to four minutes if you want to add
cheese make sure to do this when you're
two minutes away from being done you can
still stay classic with american or
cheddar cheese but this is a great time
to add blue gruyere or any other type of
cheese you want similar to diner style
burgers you can toast your buns on the
grill brush them with butter or oil and
place them on the grill for 20 to 40
seconds a heftier pub style burger
requires a stronger bun like a brioche
or portuguese bun pud burgers are great
for getting fancy
we did a classic combination of arugula
blue cheese and caramelized onions but
again it's up to you diner style burgers
are great for when you want something
fast easy delicious and more classic pub
style burgers are great when you're
feeding a crowd make sure you're getting
high quality meat you're seasoning your
beef correctly and that you're not
overcooking anything follow those tips
and your burgers will go from good to
great
burgers
okay let's get serious this is a really
big burger you should be ready
why this is my question is why is it
so big yeah i honestly don't know